Hello, listener. This is Jason Bateman along with Will Arnett and Sean Hayes for the podcast called Smart List. If that's a place you're looking for, you've found it. Congratulations. It's not a real high concept podcast. One person invites a guest. The other two don't know who that guest is, and then we chat. Here we go. Jason, do you have dogs? I don't remember. I have two dogs, both sort of cat-sized, so I'm not, I don't let them out that much. So who does let the dogs out? Oh god. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Let him answer the goddamn, this thing has been, this is a question. I have a Brussels graphon that's kind of like that dog. Sounds like a topping.
As good as it gets. Verdal that goes down the trash shoot that Jack Nicholson puts on. His name is Woody. And then there is a French bulldog named Hank, and that's, that's my dude. And do you have any references sort of post-96, or is that just, you like to stay in that? No, I don't think, oh, actually yes. The Brussels graphon was featured in a commercial a year ago. I don't remember what it was. Oh, like a Darth Vader type of thing. Oh man, what a story. You really know how to spin a- Wait, your actual dog or that type of dog? No, no, no, that type of dog. My dog. You're not training your dog for film and TV right now. No, but I'll bet you it's pretty lucrative. I've never asked those animal trainers what
they make, but I'll bet it's not a little. I made a kid's movie with a lot of dogs in it. Natasha, Leon and I did. And how do I say- What's the name of it? Show Dogs. Show Dogs. Wait, oh, really? Did that find a theater or was it mostly on the television? We'll save that for another show. Go ahead, Sean. I feel like we're cutting you off, Sean. Robin Bennett, are you leaving or are you staying on? We're staying on because we want to snap check from our guest when they sit down in one minute. Oh, great. Got it. Then we'll get the hell out of your way. Oh, I didn't know. Okay. I don't mind looking at you two while we're doing this. I prefer it. It's nice. Yeah, thank you. Stand by for one second. Surprise guest
without saying anything verbally if you could snap or clap for us if you're there. Awesome. We are golden. Beautiful. Wow, that's extensive. Big hands. Guys, what a special episode this is. Our guest today happens to have an album coming out December 18th. I've listened to it over and over again. I love every track on it. I can't wait to talk about it. The name of the album is McCartney three. What? The name of the guy is Paul McCartney. Paul McCartney. What? Look at that. Hello. No. Hi, guys. What? Wait a sec. This is so cool. He looks so much like Paul McCartney. I know I get told that all the time. God, he sounds like him too. Wait, Sean Hayes. Yeah. I'm sorry. Sir Paul McCartney, we'll get to you
in one second. Sean, how did you do this? How did you make this happen? What the hell is going on? Well, I'm telling you, Paul and I, we were in a pub throwing them back because we're both off. We're going to get the real story. We're going to get the real story soon. What an honor. Sean, keep quiet for a second. Sir, what an honor. I was just so humbled that you said yes to this. Well, I'm glad you're humbled. Yes, sir. I like people to be humbled and a little bit frightened. I'm a little bit frightened. It is a tremendous honor to have you here. You probably don't remember, but we met briefly a couple of times, very briefly. Not surprising. Years ago. On a yacht? Was it on a yacht? No. It was on
a yacht, wasn't it? I've met everyone briefly. Exactly. Paul, we're so flattered you're here today and thank you. It's really kind of surreal to be looking at you and talking to you because I've been a fan like the rest of the entire world forever. But there's a billion questions I want to ask you. Where does one start with questions? I know. There's like a billion questions. The one I've always wanted to ask you for a very, very, very long time and I'll just start right out. How are you so fit? How am I so fit? I don't think I am, of course. You look better than I did 20 years ago. You look great. You've always looked great. This is a nice show. I like you boys. Do you work out every day? No, you
know what? I do a little bit, yeah. And I'm vegetarian, so maybe that's got something to do with it. I don't know. Vegetarian, you can get sneaky fat. Having a bunch of pasta and a bunch of rice. That is true. That is true. Cheese is good. You say you do a little bit of workout. What is that? Is that a cardio thing? Do you push weight? What do I do? I have a very definite routine. I don't have a trainer. It's just me. I get on the mat and I do a bunch of stuff there like leggy sort of. Write this down, Sean. No, I've got it. Rolling on the thing, on the river. Rolling on a roller. I do a bit of that. And then I do a bit of legs of Kimbo. Sure. And then I move on to a cross trainer elliptical. And
then I do, I mean, I'm doing like five or 10 minutes of these. This is not a huge workout. But it's good. I like it. And then I do a bit of running. And then I end with my favorite bit. Particularly if I'm in a gym, because sometimes this is like a home gym. But if I'm in a gym and all the big guys, I've got big weights and they're doing all the big stuff. At the end, I do a headstand. And they come over to me. It's pretty impressive, man. Right. I go, oh, thank you. But it's just, it's nothing. I thought you were going to say, and I end with a birthday cake, which would be a fun. I think this is going to be controversial. I think that Sir Paul McCartney, you and I
should put out an exercise video together. It would be very, because we could really do that. Yeah, that'd be great. I think that people would like that. I would like it. I would watch it. You would watch it, Sean. I'll learn from it. That would be, yeah, that would be entertaining. He would spot you or you would spot him, or would you just be snacking on stuff while he's doing some cardio? It sounds like he's in better shape than I am, so I think that I would be snacking. Not difficult. Paul, first of all, where are you right now? I'm in New York. Okay. And you're in your place in New York? New York. I'm actually in my office in New York. Okay. Do you spend most of your time
in New York? No. I'm between America and England pretty much. Do you have a preference? Careful here. England. I don't care. I'm English. But the thing is that I'm married to an American girl, Nancy, and so people say, you know, how much time do you spend in the countries? I used to say half and half, but now I say half and half. Oh, nice. Well done. That's what it is. I read that you spend most of your quarantine time shocker writing more music. And to me, like, you know, I've never met you. I'm in awe of you, just like everybody else is. And you think of like, I saw you say on Stephen Colbert once that you separate your fame from you, that you, that in your head, you're just,
I just go work out and I'm nobody, but then there's this famous person that you remove yourself from. Yeah. Right. And that you kind of like, oh, I kind of like that guy's music, kind of interesting. And it's you. No, it's true. It is weird. You know, I think it's a safety measure. I think, you know, I know I'm very famous, but I don't want to walk around like I'm very famous. I like that bit that I had when I grew up. Right. Of just going on a bus and just being, you know, there's one good thing about the virus is everyone's got masks. Yeah. Yeah. Anyone with a famous face. But no, I do separate him from me. Yeah. So me, I don't like to take pictures when people say can I have a picture because everyone's
got a camera in the world. Yeah. And so I say, I'm sorry, I don't do pictures. Yeah. The line I got from watching Alec Baldwin once, we have this little thing with Lauren Alec and a couple of mates. And it's called the yoga boys. And we do yoga together. And like, we're terrible. I don't want to tangle with you guys. Anyway, so yeah, we're sitting around afterwards talking and we're having a bite to eat outdoors. Someone comes up to Alec said, can I have your autograph support? And he looks with that Alec look, he says, I'm sorry, I don't do pictures. He held it. And I just thought that's the line. Yeah. I'm sorry. I sometimes feel like I have to say, look, you know, I'm happy to talk to
you. Sit down. We could talk because I like that because I'm still me. Right. The minute I put my arm around you, you put your arm around me. I feel like the monkey in Santro pay. Yeah. Come and have a picture taken with the monkey. You know, and I don't like that. It puts me off. I love that you talk about this. So openly this idea of you being this, this person that you are and there's a sort of humility to that you attribute that to where you grew up in Liverpool and your family and those kind of ideas that you've had from a young age then that you've never let go of in a way.
Yeah, I think so. You know, I'm very lucky with my family, uncles and aunties, cousins and all of that. There were like millions of them. My dad had seven in his family. My mom had two brothers. So anyway, the minute they all start reproducing, it produced a big, big family. And it was great. They were so wonderful and wise and funny and optimistic. I really don't remember anything bad about it. So I grew up thinking that's how everyone's life is. We've all got lovely uncles. And you know, then when I met John, it turned out not to be true. He had a terrible upbringing. His dad left home when he was three. His mother got run over and killed outside his aunt's place. It's a terrible story. But yeah, so
I do attribute that to my family upbringing. And it is something I want to hold on to. And that instinct to hold on to that connection, that real human quality that we are all sort of one. And it seems like you've got a real sort of love of people. Do your level of fame and notoriety, does it sometimes sadden you that other people who are just meeting you for the first time might have trouble or difficulty connecting with you on that level? And do you then take it upon yourself to sort of try to put them at ease so that you can have that kind of, please see me as Paul and not as Paul McCartney. Let's talk, let's connect. That's right. Yeah, I do. I do that, you know. Well, because I can't really sort of sit down
and go, listen to this, let it be. We can't do that. Well, you can. I can, I suppose. But people are very interesting. People are really interesting. And you know, you ask them a question that you might think is quite boring. But sometimes they've got quite amazing stories. And I like that. I was always very curious about that. When I was a kid, I used to take a bus and just go for a few stops and get off and sit on a bench and just watch people and talk to people. In fact, I got arrested for it once. You did. So Jason, a regular person is just so we can try to put in context for Jason. Thank you.
A regular person is somebody who did not grow up in show business. Right. So they play golf. Oh boy. This might take a minute. But Paul, like on the subject of fame, just because you, you made me think of something. Have you found, do you find yourself, you especially measuring time and your life by certain milestones or events such as like the release of albums or concerts or whatever. And then therefore does that make the past feel like it's not that far away? Yeah. To some extent, you know, I think, I think so. Yeah. So, you know, I know Sergeant Pepper was 1967. Whereas most dates I don't remember, but I just happen to know what went
on that year. And so yeah, I would, I would do that. But I'm the world's worst rememberer of Beatle history. But it's, I've got an history. I think, well, there's always going to be someone who knows. So I'll just ask someone, what was it when we came to America? All that was. And where am I right now? Yeah. But what's incredible about that is that you could quite honestly, you could ask anybody, if you went to a restaurant, you could tap someone on the shoulder and they could probably tell you that date. And that's what's so incredible. Like the size and the
weight of that legacy. Does it ever, I don't even know how to ask this question. Does it, does that, does it ever feel really heavy in that way? Does it feel like a burden? It doesn't actually, because this phenomenon happened a long time ago. It's like, you know, this isn't new for me. This is like, talk about the sixties, even this was going on. But I just remember thinking, okay, now you're becoming very famous. So if you don't want the trappings of that, you should stop now. And just say, thanks guys. But to do that, I would have kind of had to get out of music. And I love that too much. So I carried on. And so you get more and more famous, et cetera. I do, however, sometimes, just when I'm being
me, the person I grew up with, because this is still the same person, you know, it's still the same body. Yeah. Yeah. And you're the only one that's been there for all of it. All those steps you've been through. Yeah. You know, but I do sometimes think, wow, God, in heaven, I mean, bloody hell, I'm a singer songwriter. How did that happen? Yeah, it's crazy. But it makes sense. Because you started, I mean, I read somewhere that you wrote when
me, the person I grew up with, because this is still the same person, you know, it's still the same body. Yeah. Yeah. And you're the only one that's been there for all of it. All those steps you've been through. Yeah. You know, but I do sometimes think, wow, god, in heaven, I mean, bloody hell, I'm a singer songwriter. How did that happen? Yeah, it's crazy. But it makes sense. Because you started, I mean, I read somewhere that you wrote when
I'm 64, well before you met John. Is that true? Yeah, when I was 16. You were 16. Yeah. You were 64. By the way, who was the 64 year old you were writing about? Everyone, a year before their retirement. 65 was when you retired. So 64 was everyone. So you've been writing about, you've been a singer songwriter your whole life, not your whole career, your whole life, like even before you probably knew you were going to do it.
You've been this. Yeah. Well, my dad was the family pianist. So, you know, I was reading like about people like Gershwin and Harold Arlen. And they said, every house had a piano. That was the way things were those days. And my dad, we had a piano and he played it. He played great. He played all the old sort of shit car go, you did all of that, you know. Did you ever study classical music? Did he or you? I didn't know. No, neither was did. And I'd say, ask him to teach me. He'd say, no, you've got to learn properly. But I didn't like the little smelly old lady.
Yeah. I mean, well, he got a deal on her. There was a more expensive teacher. He just, he couldn't use. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, I told him. So Sir Paul, one more question about your, your emotional and mental health that seems so, so clear to me. Was it always that way in the sense that with all the incredible fortune and success and, and assumed happiness throughout your life, all these incredible
stages up to and including today, do you feel that you were always in the right condition mentally, emotionally to appreciate all of that? It seems like you've, you seem like the kind of guy keeps, keeps your room clean upstairs so that you could appreciate the fame, money, all the complications that might come with that. If, if you don't have your room tidy, it can be somewhat destructive and a lot of people don't handle that well. But it seems like you're an incredibly healthy man emotionally, spiritually, mentally, as have you been able to enjoy all this incredible life you seem to have had? Yeah. I think, you know, by and large, and I tell you this family of mine, I really do
attribute it to them. Uncle Jack, all right, son. Yeah, son, you know, come on. I've heard the one about, yeah. Uncle Joe singing all the time. You know, there's just so many of these characters and they'd all just come out of World War II. You know, I was born in 1942, was actually was in that war and they all come out of it and they were all so lovely and positive that I always just thought, well, that's the way you should be. So, you know, that's, that's my kind of guiding thought is that, hey, you know, it's okay, really, we get shitty moments. But basically, it's okay. Future's going to be good. You know, it's not always easy to think that particularly these days. But, you know, COVID,
you know, I was talking to someone about this the other day and saying, it is like the war for my parents. Well, my parents go and have me in a war. When Hitler's raiding bombs on Liverpool, they couldn't have been too optimistic that they were going to win, you know, because it wasn't, but yeah, I just think this is another war. This is something instead of like HIV or SARS or avian flu that tended to happen to other people. Right. We are all going through this one together, which equates, in my mind, to war. Yeah. And I would say that you, you know, this idea that you've made it this far and kept it as Jason said, so straight upstairs and you attribute it to your family. I think that we can relate
to that. The three of us have very close relationships to our families as well. It's something that we, I think that we share. And in this time, in this COVID time, I agree with you. This is now more than ever. We really need each other, not just our families, but our friends. It's so important because it can be so isolating and that could be devastating. And to keep the positivity going during quarantine and isolation is, you know, is rough, but you know, creative types find a way and you found a way just like the rest of us, we're doing a podcast, you wrote an album, like normal people do, I guess, I don't know. But to you, I mean, you've written over a thousand, it has to be over a thousand songs, probably
more. Do you even know how many you've written? I don't count. No, it's like a year it was or how many there were. I've been told that I wrote just short of 300 with John. Wow. Wow. That's crazy. That's just shy of my 400. But do you ever get out on stage and start performing? Wait a minute. What? You've done 400? 400. Yeah, that's not my count. With John. With John. Which John? Different John. Different John. John down the street. Yeah. Different John. So do you ever get out on stage and start performing one of your thousand songs and they get lost because you're thinking of the other 900? I mean, like, do lyrics ever get crossed or whatever? Oh, yeah. Yeah. I do. That's quite a lot. That's why I have
a teleprompter. Oh, well, you can probably just ask the audience to help you with the line. That's right. No, I do that kind of thing. You know, sometimes I don't know you guys when you're performing. I don't know if it happens to you, but I'll be kind of doing a song, let's say like Eleanor Rigby or something. Yeah. And I'm on autopilot and I'm starting to think, oh, what am I going to have for dinner later? Oh, yeah. Oh, okay. Well, that's all right. Yeah. Maybe, maybe you won't have the soup, but maybe you'll just to, you know, go for the main course. And I go, stop. Yeah. Because I'm singing Eleanor Rigby. You know, I've separated myself, not only from Paul and famous, from a couple of bits of my head
are going in different places. And yeah, so sometimes that breaks down and I forget the song. I don't remember the soup. I do. Totally. I did Broadway a few times. And when you do eight shows a week for a year, you completely check out in the middle. One time I checked out right in the middle, Tony Goldman was on stage. He's a great actor. He was, and I turned to him and I go out of nowhere. I just go, what was I, what am I saying? What's my line? Yeah. But those thousand songs, like do you, and I kind of ask, I'm the one who kind of asked a lot of guests this question, which is like, do you still have that fire in your belly to keep writing and keep creating these great iconic songs
that just seem endless inside of you? Or do you feel pressure to keep doing that? No, it's like a hobby, really. I'm very lucky. So, you know, I'll go home and pick up my guitar while I'm watching TV and just tinkle around and just do something, you know. It really is something that still entrances me. That's what I say before. I'm a singer, songwriter. I'm seriously amazed by that. So yeah, you know, I will. Maybe I'm amazed. I don't know. Maybe I'm immune. Did you see the James Corden? Maybe I'm immune. Yeah. Yeah. What did you think of that? Okay, I love that. I love James. He's a good singer.
He's a great singer, isn't he? Yeah. He thinks he's better than me. I rang him up. I said, James, I said, listen, that's great. I said, I'd be so jealous if I hadn't written it. Yeah. Did you go, did you do something with James, or am I misremembering, where you went to Liverpool? Yeah, no, we did. Yeah, the Carpool Karaoke. Yeah, Carpool. Yes. That was like a big moment, right? You went back there and everybody kind of flooded in and I loved when you actually signed the Penny Lane sign. You just went up and signed it. Well, you know, the worst thing about all of that was I didn't want to do it because they'd said, you know, it'd be great. James wants you to do a carpool
and stuff. And I just thought, no, no, Adele's done it. Stevie Wonder's done it. It was so good. I'm going to go and do it and be crap. So I just sort of said, no, guys, listen, thanks, but I don't think I'll do it. And right up till the minute we got in the car, I was still bitching, which isn't like me, but I was still sort of, oh, good. In fact, I sent to James when he was taking a bit of makeup on. And I said, James, you know, one of the great things about being in the Beatles was at this kind of moment, George would probably, you know, look at everyone go, what the fuck are we doing this for? I said, I miss that. Yeah. Yeah. And his producer band was very funny. He said, that's funny. That's funny.
Get in the car. And so we got it. But now I really enjoyed it. It was great. And I'd never been in my old house since I left. By the way, who was that woman in there in the house? You know, she's the keeper of the house. Oh, she is not a housekeeper. She's it's a national trust thing. So it's like a museum. Oh, she's like the museum curator must have blown her mind to meet you. Well, I think it pretty much did. But the thing was she charged us. And she said, well, that's five pounds each. No, this is my house. Yeah, you get out. No. And then the whole thing ended with you in that bar, surprising everybody in the pub
and the curtains open and everybody's like, holy shit, that's Paul McCartney. And then you just started playing and everybody was like floored. What an incredible treat for everybody there. That was incredible. That was great. I mean, I say it was great for us too, you know, because I mean, that pub we're in where we did that stunt is one I've stood with my family with these uncles with a pint. And I had all that history with it. So it was pretty amazing just wandering around Liverpool because I was now the tour guide. We did this. But I do that anyway, when I go back to Liverpool, I do that anyway, whether you like it or not, you take him around
and I take him past this old house I used to live in. But I never used to go in. So I used to think it's going to be so disappointing. It's going to be scary or something. I don't just leave it, don't go in. That's easy. So I would sit outside the house with my guest whoever it was. There's the house. See that little window. Well, that was my bedroom. And this is the way you get through the back of your soul. And some old guy comes walking up and he looks at me and goes, Yeah, he did used to live there. Like he was sick of it. Like he'd seen it a million times. You know what? It reminds me you're obviously so iconic. And so many people have done impressions of you over the
years. And our collectively, our good friend, Peter Sarah Finowich, who's from Liverpool originally has has done an impression of you for years. He's a very funny guy. He lives in London now. A very funny comedian. First of all, what is that like throughout for the last years and years and years people have done impressions of you? Is it annoying A and B? Who was there anyone who did it? You went like, Yeah, that was pretty good. Was there one that stuck out? It's not annoying because, you know, they're talking about me. And that's okay. So that's not annoying. You know, that's good. But I don't think they quite get it. What are they missing? Well, Americans have got to sort of, Oh, hello.
Yeah. Hello. How you doing? Jimmy Fallon's pretty good. Oh, yeah. Yeah. He does a pretty good one. But generally, it's not quite, you know, but my voice has changed. I look at old interviews with the Beatles, I was much more Liverpool, you know, was very much, you know, all right, yeah. Well, now I've lived out of Liverpool much more than I ever lived in Liverpool. So your voice changes, you know. So I have a quick question about touring. Jason and I are more homebodies. I think it's safe to say in Will's kind of probably the more adventure seeker traveler. Wouldn't you guys say that's true?
I'm definitely a homebody. I don't know how much he adventures or seeks for purposes of this question. I'll roll with it. Yeah, go ahead, I mean, I toured with Kenny Rodgers and wanted off the bus after the third city. Here we go. So when you toured, don't ask him what it was. Paul, do not. I played an elf. It was, it was humiliating. Here it comes. So when you toured as much as you have for as long as you have, do you ever miss that kind of home base feeling? Like, do you ever get like, it was tough out there, right, Sean? Yeah, well, God, it was so hard. You got to take off the elf suit after every show. The elf on the bus with Kenny. And he was such a nice guy.
It was like for you too, Paul. We can relate, right? Yeah. But do you ever get depressed living out of hotels and never feeling settled and all that, like constantly touring all these years? I'm actually not too bad with that. I know you mean a lot of people don't like that. I actually quite like it because I've been doing it forever. And instead of me making me jaded, it's just something I do and I'm kind of used to. I like the room service. I was walking down the corridor in the four seasons in LA and I got this feeling like,
I like this. I like this. What do you do about getting to sleep with all the different time zones? Do you have a trick for adapting to different times? Drugs. Yeah. Nice. We got it. No, no, no. Come on. I'm really kidding. No, actually, I'm very lucky in that respect.
I just get tired during the day and I'll meet people, you know, in the evening. They say, God, I'm really tired. I said, great. Keep it up and go to bed. You know, I love that. So yeah, no, I get tired, especially after the show. And we do have to have a sort of warm down period. Jason's been doing a warm down since he was 30. Yeah. But wait, what about your ears? What about touring with all that loud music just constantly over the decades? Is it done anything?
Yeah, exactly. That's what you say. No, that's the only problem. It does go for your hearing, unfortunately. But I love it. I love it. When I was a kid in Liverpool, the idea of taking an electric guitar and plugging it in was like, it was kind of thrilling, you know. And I still get that thrill. And I'm surprised because I should be jaded. It should have worn off. But it doesn't. You know, I love it. I go in my studio making this album you're talking about. And I plug in the guitar and I'm still trying to learn how to play it. Although I have, I'm getting better.
How many weeks a year would you ideally be on the road nowadays? This year, I was supposed to be doing about 12 gigs in Europe and then Glastonbury Festival. So I was kind of looking forward to that. And I suppose I then would have gone out this time, possibly somewhere with better weather. So, you know, you go down to South America or somewhere. And I quite like it. So like a third of the year, half of the year, on average? Yeah, maybe a quarter or something. You know, it's been quite good. But there's certain periods when I want to be home. But, you know, I've been doing it long, you know, to be able
to say to my promoter, okay, end of April, first couple of weeks in May, got to be in England, because that's when the bluebells come out. Yeah. And there's, there's no, nothing like it, you know, wherever you go. What about the holidays? You like to be home around the holidays or just spring as the part that you really protect? No, I like to do Christmas. We were always home. Yeah.
Loved to do that. Thanks, Gaby, now that I'm married to American, we do that. What's the family look like nowadays? How wide is it? How many, what's the family gathering usually number out to nowadays? It would be, I've got eight grandkids. Wow, that's great. Yeah. Wow. Yeah, can you believe that?
That's amazing. That's so bad. Yeah. So hopefully it'd be with them, their moms and husbands, the rest of my kids, and my wife. Yeah. Yeah. Do you enjoy providing that kind of sane guidance that you got from your family when you were a young kid? I mean, nowadays, I would imagine it's, it's, it's almost more
太棒了。太糟糕了。是啊。所以希望它会和他们、他们的妈妈和丈夫、我的其他孩子以及我的妻子在一起。是啊。是啊。你喜欢提供那种你小时候从家人那里得到的明智指导吗？我的意思是，如今，我想这几乎更加
complicated than it was back then, given technology and culture and all that stuff. Are you, do you like playing that role, passing on that, that sanity? Yeah, I kind of do, yeah, but it's not super proactive. I leave that to their parents. Sure. Because you get the granddad interrupting, and you know, you know. We got it, dad. Yeah. Yes.
比过去复杂，考虑到技术、文化和所有这些东西。你，你喜欢扮演那个角色，传递那种，那种理智吗？是的，我有点喜欢，是的，但不是很主动。我把这个留给他们的父母。当然。因为你会遇到爷爷打断，你知道，你知道。我们懂了，爸爸。是啊。是的。
Right. It's okay, you know, leave this to us. Right. And I know that's my cue, you know. For me, you could call my mother and tell her that, that would be a great message for her to receive, to let me parent my kids. Mom, if you're listening, butt out. Yes, thank you.
对。没关系，你知道，把这个交给我们。对。我知道这是我的暗示，你知道。对我来说，你可以打电话给我母亲告诉她，这对她来说是一个很好的信息，让她让我抚养我的孩子。妈妈，如果你在听，请别插手。是的，谢谢。
By the way, that's going to be, that's going to be on a loop from Will, that's going to be on Will's phone. Sir Paul, let me take you back to you, grabbing the. You're being very reverential, Jason. What, well, you're supposed to say sir, aren't you? You don't have to. Okay. All right. Emperor.
顺便说一句，那将是，那将会在威尔的手机上循环播放，那将会在威尔的手机上。保罗爵士，让我带你回到，抓住。你表现得非常崇敬，杰森。什么，好吧，你应该叫爵士，对吧？你不用这么做。好吧。好吧。皇帝。
Boy, he dropped that pretty quick, if you let, let's go back to you grabbing the guitar, you're watching television and you're starting to, to figure out a new song or something like that. Or new lyrics. Do you have someone or some group in mind when you, when you write a song and if so does that change or are you writing for you most of the time? Well, I'm writing for me, but you're right. I often have someone in my mind who I'm kind of imitating, who's style I'm imitating.
天哪，他很快就放弃了，如果你愿意，让我们回到你拿起吉他的时候，你看电视，你开始弄懂一首新歌或类似的东西。或者新歌词。当你写歌时，你心里有某个人或某个群体吗？如果是这样，这会改变吗，还是你大部分时间都在为自己写歌？嗯，我是为自己写的，但你说得对。我经常心里想着某个人，我在模仿他，我在模仿他的风格。
And it's a great trick because it never turns out like them. Yeah. You do your version of it. Yeah. I could be doing Big Bill Brunzi. Right. And it's nothing like him, believe me. You know, on this album, I've got a track that was inspired by, I was reading a book
这是一个绝妙的把戏，因为结果永远不会像他们。是的。你做你自己的版本。是的。我可能会模仿大比尔·布朗齐。对。这跟他一点也不像，相信我。你知道，在这张专辑里，我有一首歌的灵感来自于，我正在读一本书
on Big Bill Brunzi. And yeah, and I'd started noodling on a piano, as I go and lie to my mama, I'm going by more bluesy. I'm sound just like him, but I didn't. But yeah, I do use that as a trick. I like to do that. When I was writing Longham Winding Road, I thought I was Ray Charles. Wow.
关于大比尔·布朗齐。是的，我开始在钢琴上乱弹琴，就像我对妈妈说谎一样，我要去弹更多的蓝调。我听起来就像他，但我没有。但是是的，我确实把这当成一个把戏。我喜欢那样做。当我写《The Long and Winding Road》时，我觉得自己是雷·查尔斯。哇。
But I wasn't. Wow. Turns out, yeah. But he later recorded some songs of mine, and he was Ray Charles. Wow. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, you know, that was, that's like magic. That must have been a thrill in a way, yeah?
但我不是。哇。事实证明，是的。但他后来录制了我的一些歌，他就是雷·查尔斯。哇。是啊，是啊，是啊。所以，你知道，那就像是魔法。那一定是一种震撼，对吧？
Yeah, man. You know, yeah. I mean, because, you know, we grew up with these guys, and like, we're totally in awe. I record like, what did I say when I was one of Ray's first things? Yeah. You know, I used to do that in Hamburg. That was one of our big numbers. Yeah, what I say, what I say, and then I would, you know, you get the, whoa, oh, oh, oh, oh,
是的，伙计。你知道，是的。我的意思是，因为，你知道，我们是听着这些家伙的歌长大的，就像，我们完全敬畏。我录音像，我在雷的第一首歌里说了什么？是啊。你知道，我以前在汉堡这样做过。那是我们的主打歌之一。是的，我说了什么，我说什么，然后你就会，哇，哦，哦，哦，哦，
ah, oh, ah, I would end up under the table purposely, Chopis. Did you guys ever have the, you went to Hamburg, of course, and that's, that was kind of the last step before, you'd already had some success in Liverpool, of course, then you went to Hamburg, and that's a very, you know, people know that story. And then right after that, you really broke on the international stage and became the Beatles that we know today. Was there a moment, once you looked back, sort of in that next year, after you'd really broken through, did you have a moment or many moments where you guys looked at each other
啊，哦，啊，我最终会故意躲在桌子底下，乔皮斯。你们有没有过，你们当然去过汉堡，那是，那是倒数第二步，之前，你们当然在利物浦取得了一些成功，然后你们去了汉堡，这是一个非常，你知道，人们都知道这个故事。紧接着，你就在国际舞台上大放异彩，成为了我们今天所知的披头士乐队。有没有这样一个时刻，一旦你回首往过去，在你真正大红大紫之后的第二年左右，你有没有过这样一个时刻或很多时刻，你们看着彼此
and said, wow, can you fucking believe what's going on? You know, do you remember that? Yeah. I think most of it, you know, that was because we'd been completely anonymous, and we went to Hamburg where we were still anonymous, but we kind of learned how to build a crowd. We were stuck in this bar called the Indra, which is German for India, and nobody ever came in there. And so we were just on the stage saying, you know, and then you'd see a couple of students
说，哇，你他妈能相信发生了什么吗？你知道，你还记得吗？是的。我想大部分，你知道，那是因为我们完全默默无闻，我们去了汉堡，在那里我们仍然默默无闻，但我们有点学会了如何吸引观众。我们被困在一家叫印陀（Indra）的酒吧里，这是印度在德语里的意思，从来没有人进去过。所以我们只是在舞台上说，你知道，然后你会看到几个学生
would look in and they'd main thing, they'd look at the beer price and then they'd leave because they thought it was too expensive. So we had to learn to pull them in, and it was a great lesson. So you know, we'd see the students and go, yeah, okay, we're going to dance in the street tonight. Come on. Hey, dance in the street tonight. Everybody.
会往里看，最重要的是，他们看一眼啤酒价格然后就走了，因为他们觉得太贵了。所以我们不得不学会把他们拉进来，这是一个很好的教训。所以你知道，我们会看到学生们然后说，好吧，我们今晚要在街上跳舞。来吧。嘿，今晚在街上跳舞。每个人。
I love that. Two of them. You know. But we learned. Yeah. We learned. And gradually, I must say, boasting, that place filled up, man. Yeah.
我喜欢那样。两个。你知道。但我们学会了。是的。我们学会了。渐渐地，我必须吹牛，那个地方坐满了人，伙计。是的。
I'm a word of mouth, got around that we were quite a good little group. And you know, man, this is going back so far, and we used to say to each other, do you know how long ago it was, the war, it was like 15 years ago, and we're over there like playing. Right. We had to occasionally kind of go, yeah, but we won. Right. Yeah. It's all right.
口碑传开说我们是个相当不错的小组合。你知道，伙计，这已经过去好久了，我们过去常常对彼此说，你知道距离战争有多久了吗，大概是15年前，我们在那边演出。对。我们偶尔不得不说，是的，但是我们赢了。对。没关系。
Yeah. Exactly. But it was great. You know, and we play Germany now and amazed at the kids, how cool they are, you know. But yeah, then we would be interrupted at 10 o'clock, and policemen would come on the stage and we go, what, what, what, thinking we're being arrested, you know, they go to the mic. It's just now, at 22 o'clock, we're making selection control, please, Olli Jürgenslich,
是的。没错。但这太棒了。你知道，我们现在去德国演出，对那些孩子们的酷劲感到惊讶，你知道。但是，是的，到了10点钟，我们会被打断，警察会走上台，我们说，什么，什么，什么，以为我们要被逮捕了，你知道，他们走向麦克风。现在是22点，我们要进行选择控制，请，奥利·于尔根斯利希，
under 18 years, leave this club. So it's like, it's 10 o'clock, you know, if you haven't got your passport with you and you're under 18, get out. Wow. So it was kind of, it was a different world. Wow, man. We were, we were kids, we were like, you know, 18, 19. So that was real German, you learned German back then, and you've remembered it?
18岁以下，离开这个俱乐部。所以就像10点钟一样，你知道，如果你随身没有护照而且未满18岁，那就滚出去。哇。所以这有点，这是一个不同的世界。哇，伙计。我们是，我们是孩子，我们大约，你知道，18、19岁。所以那是真正的德国人，你当时学了德语，而且你还记得？
I know a bit of German, yeah, I screwed it up there, but I do know a bit of German. Sounded convincing to me. Yeah. We were none the wiser. I was like, yeah. I learned in school. Me and George were the only two who'd learned it in school, who we did. Is there an artist, an art figure either alive or maybe even dead before you were even born,
我知道一点德语，是的，我在那儿说砸了，但我确实知道一点德语。听起来对我很管用。是的。我们什么都不知道。我就想，是的。我是从学校学的。我和乔治是仅有的两个在学校学过的人，我们学了。有没有哪个艺术家，无论是还活着还是甚至在你出生前就已经去世的艺术人物，
that you are so sort of in awe of, humbled by and enamored by, that Present company excluded, obviously, sorry, let me just. That you assume or hope, perhaps, would have the same effect over you that you assume you have over others, if that makes any sense, you know? Yeah, Elvis. Yeah. I love Elvis, and he really was huge for us, and we ended up meeting him. Which is, you know, that's a zany moment, because I do have to kind of think, did I
让你如此敬畏、谦卑和倾倒，以至于当场的人除外，当然，对不起，让我……你假设或希望，也许，会对你产生同样的影响，就像你假设你对其他人产生的影响一样，如果这有任何意义的话，你知道吗？是的，埃尔维斯。是的。我爱埃尔维斯，他对我真的意义重大，我们最后见到了他。这你知道，这是一个疯狂的时刻，因为我确实不得不去想，我真的
really meet him? Yeah, you did. Yeah, I really met Elvis, and was he cool? Yeah, he was really cool, and he lived up to all our expectations, you know. Were you guys at a level of fame where he was sort of talking to you as a peer, as a colleague, or were you guys still just coming up at that point? Well, we were the kids on the block who were going to wipe him off the block, which was kind of very embarrassing, because we didn't want to do that, we loved him so much.
见到他了吗？是的，你见到了。是的，我真的见到埃尔维斯了，他酷吗？是的，他真的很酷，他没有辜负我们的所有期望，你知道。你们当时的知名度是否达到了他把你们当成同龄人、同行来交谈的程度，还是你们当时仍然只是刚刚崭露头角？嗯，我们是街区里要把他赶出街区的孩子们，这有点非常尴尬，因为我们不想那样做，我们太爱他了。
So he would be the one, Dylan, I love, I love him, you know. What about today, like there's so many pop acts these days, you know, with an emphasis on the package, rather than the quality of the music and the musicianship, almost kind of trying to manufacture what the Beatles, you know, were authentically, so do you listen to anybody today? Is there an actual artist, or like a boy band or group that you listen to because of that true artistry? Yeah, I mean, you know, for me, it's not really because of the music, like it is for the fans.
所以他会是那个人，迪伦，我爱，我爱他，你知道。现在的流行歌手怎么样，比如现在有那么多流行乐坛的艺人，你知道，更注重包装而不是音乐品质和音乐造诣，几乎有点像在人为制造当年披头士乐队那种真正的光芒，所以你现在还听谁的歌吗？有没有哪个真正的艺术家，或者像男孩乐队或组合，因为这种真正的艺术性而吸引你去听？是的，我的意思是，你知道，对我来说，其实不是因为音乐，不像粉丝那样。
For me, it's like, yeah, just seeing some young kids go through what we went through. BTS, Korean guys. Yeah. You know, I like watching them, seeing what's going on. Yeah. I think they're good. You know, like I said, I couldn't sing one of their songs, but I like that. And there are some people though, who are not just manufactured, like Taylor Swift.
对我来说，就像，是的，只是看到一些年轻人经历我们经历过的事情。防弹少年团（BTS），韩国小伙子。是的。你知道，我喜欢看他们，看看发生了什么。是的。我觉得他们很好。你知道，就像我说的，我唱不出他们的一首歌，但我就喜欢那样。不过也有一些人，不只是人工制造的，比如泰勒·斯威夫特。
For her, she's a true singer-songwriter. She's like pretty cool. She's the real deal. I met up with her recently, a lot of fun. I have a question about songwriting, but it's okay if I can like geek out for a second about music. Did you ever study music theory, by the way? No.
对她来说，她是一个真正的唱作人。她挺酷的。她是货真价实的。我最近见过她，非常有趣。我有一个关于歌曲创作的问题，不过如果我能为音乐疯狂一下，也没关系。顺便问一下，你学过乐理吗？没有。
Wow. And this is the whole thing about, just before your question, the whole thing about all the groups out in Liverpool, not one of them, well, unless you were a sax player, and then you had to learn a bit of music, but none of us knew anything. You know, all the guys in the groups, I was talking to Jeff Lane about it. He said, we just made it all up, didn't we? Right, right. And that's why it was, we just, you know, taught each other chords and made it up.
哇。这就是全部的重点，就在你的问题之前，利物浦所有乐队的重点，没有一个，嗯，除非你是个萨克斯手，然后你必须学一点音乐，但我们谁也不知道。你知道，组合里的所有家伙，我和杰夫·莱恩聊过这个。他说，我们都是瞎编的，对吧？对，对。这就是为什么，我们只是，你知道，互相教和弦然后瞎编。
So none of us studied. Yeah, Sean, they didn't need to go to school, Sean, like some music nerd. They had it in them. Yeah, I was a music nerd. You can't manufacture it from a book, my word. You know what? I'm going to get, I'm going to ask for my money back then, from my college. No, then maybe you're not even aware you do this, but I'm like hyper-aware about tempo
所以我们谁都没学过。是的，肖恩，他们不需要去上学，肖恩，不像某些音乐书呆子。他们天生就有。是的，我以前是个音乐书呆子。你无法从书本里凭空捏造出来，真的。你知道吗？那我得去要回我的学费了，从我的大学。不，那可能你甚至都没有意识到你在这样做，但我对节奏超级敏感
and time signatures and phrasing, like some of your most iconic melodies. Well, for example, like, I love you is like very straightforward, like I two, three, four love you, you know, it's very straightforward. It's on the beat, nothing syncopated at all or anything. But then like one of my all-time favorite songs in the history of the world is No More Lonely Nights. And you do like two beats a measure, then four beats a measure, then two beats, and then four beats, and then you keep four beats.
和拍号以及分句，就像你一些最具标志性的旋律。嗯，例如，比如，我爱你（I love you）非常直白，就像我二、三、四爱你，你知道，非常直白。它在拍子上，一点切分音也没有或者别的什么。但随后就像我世界历史上最喜欢的歌曲之一《No More Lonely Nights》（不再孤独的夜晚）。你的小节是两拍，然后四拍，然后两拍，然后四拍，然后保持四拍。
Like it's crazy, brilliant, and bizarre at the same time. It's like in the world of Broadway, it's Sondheim. You know what I mean? Like, like if the phrase is, and if it takes a couple of years to turn your tears to laughter, and if it takes a couple of years, it's four beats, turn your tears to, and that's two, laughter is three, is four beats again, which is so bizarre. So do you doing this consciously or are you doing? No.
就像它疯狂、辉煌而又诡异。这就像在百老汇的世界里，就是桑德海姆。你知道我的意思吗？就像，如果乐句是，“And if it takes a couple of years to turn your tears to laughter”（如果需要几年时间将泪水化为笑声），“and if it takes a couple of years”（如果需要几年时间）是四拍，“turn your tears to”（将你的泪水化为）那是两拍，“laughter”（笑声）是三，又是四拍，这太诡异了。所以你是有意这样做的还是在做？没有。
I'm just wasting everyone's time explaining that. I love that you've analyzed it that much. No idea what you're talking about. It just sounded good to you, and so you kept it going that way, right? Yeah, that's my question. Like do you write the then? That's the greatest answer I could have hoped for. This is one of the greatest moments of my life.
我只是在浪费大家的时间来解释这些。我喜欢你对它进行了如此深入的分析。根本不知道你在说什么。它听起来对你很好，所以你就这样继续下去了，对吧？是的，这就是我的问题。那你写的时候吗？这是我能得到的最好的回答。这是我一生中最伟大的时刻之一。
You write the melodies and the lyrics, and then you just, whatever, without thinking, and then you build the foundation underneath it. Yeah. I mean, there's no theory behind it at all. We'll cut all that out, and so. No, no, no, no. We're going to replay it on a loop. And sometimes it's music first and lyric second and vice versa.
你写出旋律和歌词，然后你只是，不管怎样，不经思考，然后在它下面建立地基。是的。我的意思是，背后根本没有什么理论。我们会把这些都剪掉，所以。不，不，不，不。我们要循环播放它。有时候是先有音乐后有歌词，反之亦然。
Yeah. Is there a set way that you went about things or no? Yeah. I mean, the best is when you get the two together and you just discovered your melody and you got some words and you just follow that trail and you just carry on with that thought and then you subvert it maybe for the middle or whatever. I mean, I've got tricks, but they're not musically notated. I wouldn't know about that, but I know we were good at it.
是的。你处理事情有一套固定的方式吗，还是没有？是的。我的意思是，最好的是当你把这两者结合在一起，你刚刚发现了你的旋律，你有一些词，然后你顺着那个线索，你带着那个想法继续下去，然后在中间部分或者其他地方颠覆它。我的意思是，我有一些小把戏，但它们不是音乐记谱。我对此一无所知，但我知道我们很擅长。
Yeah. It's nobody was doing it. You would have like crazy, like the song would just change like in Bohemian Rhapsody by Queen. Yeah. Like had sections. You guys invented that. Yeah.
是的。没有人这么做。你会像皇后乐队的《波西米亚狂想曲》那样疯狂，就像歌曲会突然改变一样。是的。就像有不同的段落。你们发明了那个。是的。
No, it's a great thing. And I think, you know, very proud that knowing nothing other than love and music. Yeah. It's a little bit of a theory, but I never want to put people off who learn like you obviously have. I think that is great too. It's not as great, but yeah, it's not quite as great. No.
不，这是一件很棒的事。而且我认为，你知道，非常自豪，除了爱和音乐之外一无所知。是的。有一点理论，但我从来不想把像你显然学过的那样的人吓跑。我也觉得这很棒。虽然没那么棒，但是，是的，没有那么棒。不。
No. But he's just said it's not as great. Because I'm asking you the question. There's no question, Sean. You don't need to ask him. He's already said it's not as great. No, but you know, the thing is when, when you're just thinking it, instead of reading it, there's something very good about that.
不。但他刚刚说没那么棒。因为我在问你问题。没有问题，肖恩。你不需要问他。他已经说过没那么棒了。不，但是你知道，事情是这样的，当你只是在脑子里想，而不是去阅读它时，这有一种非常好的地方。
Yeah. Yeah. For sure. It's just in you. Yeah. And you're not taking it off a page. It just feels like, yeah, this is good. This sounds okay.
是的。是的。肯定的。它就在你心里。是的。你不是从纸上摘抄的。感觉就像，是的，这很好。这听起来不错。
Right. And so you just sort of keep going till you've got it and then you try and remember it. You say that writing music, you sort of consider it somewhat of a hobby. Aside from that, what is your current hobby? Are you, do you, do you feel your day doing anything that people would be surprised to learn any sort of gardening or golf or driving fast and breaking laws? Horse riding. Really?
对。所以你只要继续下去，直到你掌握了它，然后你试着记住它。你说写音乐，你某种程度上把它当作一种爱好。除此之外，你目前的爱好是什么？你，你觉得你的一天在做什么会让大家感到惊讶的事情，比如园艺、高尔夫或者开快车违章？骑马。真的吗？
Yeah. Yeah. I like the horse riding. Yeah. You can go deep on that, right? The sneaky, specific, subtle artistry to all of that. Yeah. Yeah.
是的。是的。我喜欢骑马。是的。你可以在那上面深入研究，对吧？所有这些背后都有鬼祟、具体、微妙的艺术性。是的。是的。
I love it. Yeah. And again, I never, I never had a listen. I was a very good horse rider. And so when we married, she'd never had her own horse. So I was able to get her own horse and, you know, so she just would show me and I would fall off a lot. Yeah.
我喜欢它。是的。而且再说一次，我从来没有，我从来没有听过。我是一个非常好的骑手。所以当我们结婚时，她从来没有过自己的马。所以我能够给她买一匹属于她自己的马，你知道，所以她就会教我，而我经常从上面摔下来。是的。
But I was younger then. Sure. I still fall off, but just a bit. But yeah, so I just developed a love of it. And you know, kind of things she'd say to kind of help me with it would be, it's just a great big poppy that allows you to sit on his back. Once you think of a horse like that, it's much better. Right.
但我当时更年轻。当然。我现在还是会摔下来，只是少一点。但是，是的，所以我对它产生了一种热爱。你知道，她用来帮我掌握它的那种话会是，它只是一匹允许你坐在它背上的大矮马。一旦你把马这样想，就会好得多。对。
Speaking of better things, McCartney three, you say three, right? Three. Yeah. Yeah. That's your new album. And I listened to every track way more than once. I absolutely love it. Some of my favorite, I love all of them, but some of my favorite tracks are Seize the Day,
说到更好的事情，McCartney III，你说是III，对吧？III。是的。是的。那是你的新专辑。我每一首歌都不止听了一遍。我太喜欢它了。我最喜欢的一些，我所有的都喜欢，但其中我最喜欢的几首是《Seize the Day》，
The Kiss of Venus, and Winterbird is probably my favorite. Wow. Thank you. Yeah. It's super somber. Kind of reminds me of, you know, older Paul McCartney songs, but it's just beautiful. And I can't believe you just spit these songs out like it's nothing during quarantine. It's crazy.
《The Kiss of Venus》，还有《Winterbird》可能是我的最爱。哇。谢谢。是的。它超级忧郁。有点让我想起，你知道，保罗·麦卡特尼早期的歌曲，但它就是很美。我不敢相信你在隔离期间就像顺便一样创作出这些歌，太疯狂了。
You had a bunch of these songs. I heard you say that you, correct me if I'm wrong, that you had been working on them for a while or they'd been kind of in your head for a while. Yeah. Is that right? Yeah. I live from where I live. So I like to drive over and go to work.
你有很多这样的歌。我听你说过，如果你说错了请纠正我，你已经创作了一段时间了，或者它们已经在你的脑海里呆了一段时间了。是的。是这样吗？是的。我住在我的居所。所以我喜欢开车去上班。
Some people have the studio at home, but I'm not that keen on that because you never go to work or never come home. I'm in my studio at home right now. Are you? Yeah. Music studio. No, no, no, a voice studio. Oh, yeah.
有些人把工作室设在家里，但我不太喜欢那样，因为你永远不用去上班，也永远不用回家。我现在就在家里的音乐工作室里。是吗？是的。音乐工作室。不，不，不，一个语音工作室。哦，是的。
Right. Well, that makes sense. But so yeah, I go to the studio and some days I'll just say, okay, let's make something up. And that freedom is very nice. So I'll make something up and then sometimes they don't get finished by the end of the day. And then maybe the next day I've got to do something else.
好吧，那说得通。所以，是的，我去工作室，有时我只是说，好吧，让我们创作点什么。那种自由度非常好。所以我创作点什么，有时到了一天结束时还没完成。然后也许第二天我得做点别的。
So there were a couple of tracks like that and there were a couple of tracks that I'd written fully. So I finished the ones that were unfinished and then started and finished the next one and just went through them all just thinking, well, this is good, you know, this is like spring cleaning. You know, this is nice. They've got them all and they're all going to be finished now. That'll be nice.
所以有几首歌是那样的，还有几首歌是我已经完全写好了。所以我完成了那些未完成的，然后开始并完成了下一首，把它们都过了一遍，心里想着，嗯，这很好，你知道，这就像春大扫除。你知道，这很好。把它们都搞定了，现在它们都要完成了。那将是美好的。
But like after about 10 of them, I'd finished and I thought it's probably an album. And it was, it was Gartney 3. I love it. I absolutely love that one. And just to remind you guys, the album comes out December 18th and it's called McCartney 3. I'm going to let you go because we've taken way too much of your time. No.
但大概写了10首左右之后，我都完成了，我想这可能是一张专辑。果不其然，这就是《McCartney III》。我喜欢它。我绝对喜欢这张。提醒大家一下，这张专辑将于12月18日发行，名叫《McCartney III》。我要放你走了，因为我们占用了你太多时间。不。
No, I want to stay. Come over. And I want to know if you had to pick your favorite song you've ever written. Oh, boy. That's always a very difficult question. And I always answer yesterday, but it's a very difficult question because then the next minute I'll go long on your road. And then actually the other one I had here, there and everywhere, I'll say that Blackbird,
不，我想留下来。过来吧。我想知道如果你必须挑出你写过的最喜欢的歌。哦，天哪。这总是一个非常困难的问题。我总是回答《Yesterday》（昨天），但这真的是个非常困难的问题，因为接下来一分钟我就会说《The Long and Winding Road》（漫长而曲折的路）。然后实际上我这里还有另一首，《Here, There and Everywhere》（这里、那里和到处），我会说那首《Blackbird》（黑鸟），
you know, it kind of changes. And you know, really, I often say to people, look, I can't choose because it's like choosing one of my babies. Yeah. Yeah. You write a lot of songs with the word bird in them. Yeah. Yeah.
你知道，这总是会变。你知道，真的，我经常对人们说，听着，我无法选择，因为这就像在我的孩子们中间选择一个。是的。是的。你写了很多歌名里带鸟的歌。是的。是的。
Blackbird. Yeah, I do. Winterbird. Bird stuff. I'm an old mythologist. Which is your favorite child? This is a good question. This is a good question.
黑鸟。是的，我写过。Winterbird。鸟类相关的。我是一个老鸟类学家。哪个是你的最爱？这是一个好问题。这是一个好问题。
Wow. That's easy. That's easy. We're going to hold you to it. Yeah. Just us. That is, it's a sore point in the family is one of them keeps saying, I'm the golden child, right?
哇。这很简单。这很简单。我们要让你兑现承诺。是的。只有我们。那是，这是家里一个痛点，其中一个总是在说，我是金童，对吧？
Well, no, it's very difficult. I love you. You know, it just occurs to me as you sort of start to list off all your songs and it reminds me of, I think everybody has very vivid memories of the first time they heard a Beatles song and who it was who introduced them to your music. And I remember it was an old tapes that my parents had. And I remember my parents playing the Beatles for me the first time. And just those, when I think about it, and sometimes when I, when I listen to a Beatles
嗯，不，这非常困难。我爱你。你知道，当我开始盘点你的所有歌曲时，我突然意识到，这让我想起，我想每个人对第一次听到披头士歌曲的记忆都非常鲜活，是谁把你引向了你的音乐。我记得那是父母留下的旧磁带。我记得我父母第一次为我播放披头士的音乐。当我想到这些，有时当我，当我听一首披头士的
song, it reminds me of memories of my parents, here we go, of those great times here come the waterworks. I'm going to try to cry. I cannot cry. I'm cute. He tries so hard. That's why you do voiceovers. That's why I do voiceovers.
歌时，它让我想起了关于我父母的记忆，开始了，那些美好的时光，泪水要涌出来了。我要试着哭出来。我哭不出来。我很可爱。他太努力了。这就是你为什么要做画外音。这就是我为什么要做画外音。
And Ricky Gervais always says that he said to me recently, he said, he says, I don't know why you bother working out. Nobody ever sees you. But and he's not wrong. But this connection, your music, the connection and how it connects us to the people who are important in our lives. And I realize how much that is. I'm one of billions of people who have had that experience.
里奇·热维斯（Ricky Gervais）总是这么说，他最近对我说，他说，他说，我不知道你为什么费劲健身。从来没有人看到过你。但是，他也没说错。但这层联系，你们的音乐，这种联系以及它是如何将我们与生命中重要的人联系在一起的。我意识到这是多么深刻。我是体验过这种经历的数十亿人之一。
What an incredible, I don't know, I don't even know how to describe it. What an incredible thing to be part of people's emotional connections to the people in their lives. Almost a part of us as a human being. I guess it's not even a question. It's more of a thank you and how incredibly profound that is, you know, it is something I really appreciate because, you know, being a family man, I'll see that in my audience. I remember doing a thing in South America, a big audience, but near the front, there
多么不可思议的，我不知道，我甚至不知道该怎么形容。成为人们与生活中重要之人的情感联系的一部分，这是多么不可思议的事情。几乎成为了我们人类的一部分。我想这甚至都算不上一个问题。更多的是一份感谢，以及那是多么不可思议的深刻，你知道，这是我真的很感激的事情，因为，你知道，作为一个顾家的男人，我在观众中也能看到这一点。我记得在南美洲演出时，观众很多，但在前排，
was this very good looking man with a beard, dark-haired man. And he had his arm around this beautiful girl, long, dark hair. And I was doing Let It Be, which is kind of emotional for me because it was to do with my mother and stuff. And I just see her looking up at her dad and it was like, oh my God, it choked me, it was difficult to get through the song because there's suddenly the significance of that, that my little song that I had never even studied for, you know, it's just come out of the blue.
有这个长着胡子的英俊男人，黑发男子。他搂着这个漂亮的女孩，留着长长的黑发。我当时在唱《Let It Be》，这对我来说有点情绪化，因为这与我的母亲和其他事情有关。我看到她抬头看着她爸爸，那感觉就像，哦天哪，我哽咽了，很难把歌唱完，因为突然间意识到了那种意义，我这首甚至从未学过的歌，你知道，它就这样凭空出现了。
And my God, it's had this effect and they're having this really bonding moment. So it is something I'm very proud of and appreciate, you know, that that happens with people. I do have to pinch myself though, because it's like, are you really that guy, just that? Because I'm so busy trying to keep myself separate from him so that I can be normal. You are and you have shared that part of you with us for this hour, thank you, and our listener for that, and all the music through your life with all the millions and millions of people that have found a connection with it. So I just can't thank you enough for all of that, I'm truly, truly humbled to have spent
天哪，它竟然有这种效果，他们正在经历一段真正的羁绊时刻。所以这是让我感到非常自豪和感激的事情，你知道，这发生在人们身上。不过我确实得掐自己一下，因为这就像，你真的是那个家伙吗，仅仅是那样？因为我太忙于努力把自己和他分离开来，以便我能保持正常。你确实是，而且你今天花了一个小时和我们分享了你的一部分，谢谢你，也为了我们的听众，以及通过你生命中的音乐与数以百万计与之产生共鸣的人。所以我真的无法足够地感谢你所做的一切，能够与你共度
this time with you. Thank you very, very much. Same, same, same. Thank you so much. Well, thanks guys. I mean, I've really enjoyed this. This is a fun hour for me. Good.
这段时光，我感到由衷的、真正的荣幸。非常非常感谢。一样，一样，一样。非常感谢。好吧，谢谢你们。我的意思是，我真的很享受。对我来说这是一个有趣的时刻。太好了。
So thanks very much for the compliments. Yes. We love you. Yeah. Truly. Thank you very, very much for doing this. Have a great rest of the day. Cheers.
非常感谢你们的夸奖。是的。我们爱你。是的。真的。非常非常感谢你们做这一切。祝你们余下的时光过得愉快。干杯。
Thanks. My God, Sean. Wow. How about that? You know, can I just say one of my favorite things was watching Jason at the beginning and he was so calm and he had so much stuff that he wanted to do and stuff that he was talking about and then when you revealed this Paul McCartney, just the contrast between the two Jason's.
谢谢。天哪，肖恩。哇。怎么样？你知道，我能说我最喜欢的事情之一就是看杰森一开始的样子，他那么冷静，他有那么多想做的事和想谈论的话题，然后当你透露出这位是保罗·麦卡特尼时，两个杰森之间的反差。
He talks about the two poles, the contrast when he's like, holy fuck Paul McCartney. I'd like to think there's like four or five Jason's. I mean, too, by the way, but I thought for sure you were kidding. I mean, who would you, ladies and gentlemen, Paul McCartney was like, well, yeah, like who did you book? Right. Isn't that crazy? And then he revealed that he was actually there.
他谈到两个保罗，反差就在他觉得“卧槽，保罗·麦卡特尼”的时候。我愿意相信有四五个杰森。我是说，两个，顺便说一句，但我原以为你肯定是在开玩笑。我是说，你会，女士们先生们，保罗·麦卡特尼就像是，好吧，是的，就像你预约了谁？对。这不是太疯狂了吗？然后他透露他真的在那儿。
I just, one day you'll tell me how this all came together. How about the fact that we got to kind of like what Will was saying at the end, which is, you know, there are no words like, you know, everybody puts them on a pedestal and rightfully so. But how about we in our lifetime got to speak to him? Not a lot of people get that time, you know. And not just meet him and get the picture that you can show like what she doesn't do. But the idea that we got to talk to him and, you know, and ask questions and have him give
我只是，总有一天你会告诉我这一切是如何促成的。就像威尔最后所说的，那就是，你知道，没有词语可以形容，你知道，每个人都把他们高高捧起，这是理所应当的。但我们在有生之年能和他对话，这是多么难得。没多少人有那种时间，你知道。不仅仅是见到他并拍一张你可以拿来炫耀的照片，而是我们能和他交谈，你知道，提出问题并让他给出
you really thoughtful answers. Yeah. That'll be one of these things that you'll be able to tell your grandkids. Yeah. And for all of us that were listening to this, I just find it really just amazing that we're able to get a perspective from somebody in such a rarefied space. I'm not saying he's any better or worse than anybody else listening to this, but the unique experience that he's had in his life.
非常深思熟虑的回答。是的。这将是你以后能向孙子孙女们讲述的事情之一。是的。对于所有听这一段的人来说，我只是觉得非常不可思议，我们能够从一个处于如此崇高地位的人那里获得一个视角。我不是说他比听这个节目的任何其他人更好或更坏，而是他在生活中拥有独特的经历。
I mean, he's better. I'm sorry. He's better. I'm sure there's a, there's a gazillion things that we could have and should have asked him. But I'm glad that we got at least a window into, you know, what his human perspective is behind sort of the celebrity sort of veneer that we all assume that he's wrapped in. Yeah. I mean, and isn't it wild that somehow every human on the planet, it feels like we come
我的意思是，他就是更好。对不起。他更好。我确信有无数的事情我们本可以也应该问他。但我很高兴我们至少能透过一扇窗户，看到名人外表之下的真实人性视角，而我们通常都以为他被这些光环包裹着。是的。我的意思是，难道不是很疯狂吗，不知何故，地球上的每个人，感觉我们都是
out of our mother's wombs born knowing all the lyrics to all the songs? Yeah. Like I can't explain how I know all the words. I just do. And I know all the song. I said it was a cassette. I think it was an eight track that my, that my mom had in her, in her old car. Yeah.
从母亲的子宫里生下来就知道所有歌曲的歌词？是的。就像我无法解释我是怎么知道所有词的。我就是知道。我知道所有的歌。我说过那是一盒磁带。我想那是妈妈在她的旧车里的一盘八轨磁带。是的。
I had an eight track of a Wings album. Yeah. Just like crazy. And so when you think about it, I can remember what those covers look like. I can remember that feeling of being in that room or in the car or being with my parents and what that relationship was. It's all associated with that, with the Beatles. And when you hear it, anytime you hear that song, sensorily, you get that same.
我有一盘Wings乐队专辑的八轨磁带。是的。简直太疯狂了。所以当你回想起来，我能记起那些专辑封面的样子。我能记起那种身处那个房间、车里或和父母在一起的感觉，以及那种关系是什么。这一切都与它、与披头士乐队联系在一起。当你听到它时，无论何时听到那首歌，在感官上，你都会得到同样的。
And how long do you think it takes after talking about somebody so iconic to switch your brain back to looking at us two idiots? For me? Yeah. I just. Or me looking at you two idiots. I just love that he shut, when he said that he doesn't know what you're talking about. That was a Bateman question, by the way.
在谈论了如此标志性的人物之后，你觉得需要多久才能把你的大脑切换回看着我们这两个白痴？我吗？是的。我只是。或者我看你们两个白痴。我只是喜欢他挂电话的时候，当他说他不知道你在说什么。顺便说一句，那是一个贝特曼式的问题。
That was a Bateman question. It was a Bateman question. And then he answered it with, I don't know what you're talking about. That's usually what I get. But I got to tell you, are you like me in that you're an incredibly comforted by sort of this confirmation, because I kind of heard this or maybe even seen this from his other interviews, but the comment that he's so human, that there's this person that has been through what he has been through, accomplished what he has accomplished.
那是贝特曼式的问题。那是贝特曼式的问题。然后他回答说，我不知道你在说什么。这通常是我得到的回答。但我得告诉你，你是不是和我一样，对这种确认感到无比的宽慰，因为我以前在其他采访中听过甚至看过这种说法，但他真的很人性化，这个经历过他所经历的一切、取得过他所取得的成就的人。
But at the end of the day, he seems most proud of, most intent on, spends most of his time each day being just Paul. And then that's really important to him. And without that, he probably wouldn't be able to appreciate all the things that he's been through to the extent that he has. Of course. And maybe you can use that, like, I don't know, I don't know, I'm asking both of you, but maybe Jason, for example, you could use that as a way to becoming a normal person.
但归根结底，他似乎最引以为豪的是、最全心投入的是、每天花最多时间做的事，就是仅仅做保罗。这对他是真正重要的。如果没有这一点，他可能无法像现在这样去感激他所经历过的一切。当然。也许你可以利用这一点，就像，我不知道，我不知道，我在问你们俩，但也许杰森，你可以把它当作成为一个正常人的途径。
Do you think that's possible? It's a hurtful landing to that plan. I saw it coming. By the way, I'd be remiss if I didn't say, bye. Bye. Bye. You can always feel it coming. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你觉得这可能吗？这对那个计划来说是个沉重的打击。我预料到了。顺便说一句，如果我不说“再见”，我就会失职的。再见。再见。你总能感觉到它要来了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。